one episode you recount in your book is
around sponsors uh and there was a male
executive who noticed that or actually
you told him
um he was like hey why don't you talk
more in these meetings and you're like
actually I do talk and then I get cut
off anytime I do it and then he's like
what and then he paid attention the next
time and then saw someone cut you off
and then the person who cut you off then
reached out to you individually later to
apologize you realized it was because
this male sponsor actually nudged him
and said hey man you're totally cutting
step off but I mean you know maybe you
did it to other women too in some cases
it's helpful to have uh allies in what
you call sponsors that that help clear
the way yeah I mean first of all we we
talk about mentors and sponsors mentors
give you advice and sponsors open doors
and they're the ones who take action and
in this case my manager I mean he was a
great manager by the way even before
this but he just
you know before he but one thing that
really I struggled with was he would say
why don't you speak up more I'm like
have you watched me try to talk because
I had committed to being an extrovert at
work so I tried but in the meetings we
were in he noticed I wasn't talking and
so I read you know so I tried to speak a
couple times and he realized I was cut
off immediately but what he did was so
powerful which is he said I see you and
I'm going to address this so he didn't
actually tell me he was going to do this
but the next time I was cut off
that person apologized and I said he
reached out to you didn't he and I
thanked him because behind the scenes
he's making it easier for someone like
me who's extremely you know I'm already
introverted and so every time I got
spoken over in my head I was like what
if I'm saying something wrong what if
you know I'm not smart enough and I was
internalizing the feedback of getting
cut off as saying hey maybe you're not
good enough whereas maybe an extrovert
wouldn't have reacted that way but it
helped me to really see that I needed
somebody to say you know what I have
your back and I have your back right now
and I'm gonna have your back every
single time that this happens again and
by the way it never happened again
because he was he was actually there
making sure it wasn't going to happen in
this meeting
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang-up new
guest thank you